the 1980s turned out to be a pivotal
decade in the history of work so let
look at what happened during that decade
and why we should care about these
developments because it will affect the
future of work going forward the 1970s
are going to go down in history as a
decade of status quo the pressures were
building but managers and workers and
unions and the government behaved as if
the 1960s the 1950s were still in vogue
unions were declining new industries
were coming along with new ways of
introducing flexible job designs the
economy was experiencing this high rate
of inflation with no growth in wages
labor law was getting outdated but
Congress couldn't do anything about it
so the pressures were building like this
proverbial frog that was in warm water
stayed in the water too long until it
started to boil never jumped out because
the challenges were only being felt
incrementally until it was too late so
what happened in the 1980s the President
of the United States well Ronald Reagan
got elected president a change from a
Democrat to a conservative Republican
with very strong ideas about how to run
the economy the second thing that
happened is it coincided with a great
recession of 1981 to 1983 where the
effort was to try to break the back of
inflation by the Federal Reserve Board
the third thing that came along in
coincidence with these pressures was the
growth of Japanese and other global
competition now companies in Japan could
build autos and other products as
productively at lower costs as the
United States and build them at high
qualities so that they were strong
competitors to this country so what did
we see happen well somewhere in this
time period that great social contract
from the 1940s through the 1960s broke
down this nice coincidence of wages and
productivity moving together during this
time period you can see it began to fray
in the 70s and then after 1980
they depart never to return again so how
did this happen well again it starts
with Ronald Reagan in the August of 1981
the air traffic controllers went on
strike illegally and Ronald Reagan said
this is an illegal strike I'm going to
take decisive action I'm going to fire
them if they don't come back to work he
did so he broke that stripe and it
fundamentally changed the tenor of Labor
Relations companies in the private
sector became much more aggressive
building on the model of what Reagan did
they demanded wage concessions to try to
become more competitive they put in what
we're called two-tier contracts so new
workers were starting at work at a lower
wage rate than more senior workers that
in fact continues today in many cases
auto workers would understand this
because new hires come in about thirty
percent less than workers who are doing
the same work alongside of them and so
this persisted basically what happened
is pattern bargaining that engine that
helped to spread wage increases across
the economy broke down the bargaining
power that workers got from strikes was
no longer there strikes became defensive
weapons and companies like Greyhound bus
lines or Eastern Airlines where strikes
occurred that companies either one the
strike or in Easterns case the company
went out of business and all the jobs
were lost and so this has continued
workers lost their source of power they
don't have a new source of bargaining
power in place yet and so this social
contract continues to be broken the
challenge that we face today the
challenge as next-generation workers you
face is to figure out what is a social
contract that might work in the modern
economy for you as a modern workforce
and for society we have not figured that
out yet that's going to be your
challenge
you